welcome back if you didn't know by now i
love all things flower i work under
flower film sour beauty flower home
flower this flower that
and um i do think that having flowers in
the home
can be a real mood booster and a total
visual game changer but sometimes
i spend money on flowers and then they
die and then i'm sad and i feel like i
wasted money so then i don't buy them
for a while and then i'm not living in
that joy so there is something to drive
flowers or the process of drying them
that i wanted to talk about on the show
and our next guest is a horticulturist
and floral guru he's actually someone
who i'm very close with he's helped me
transform my home into a beautiful oasis
some dried some fresh and today he's
here back with us again for more flower
diy tips that you can try at home please
welcome christopher freeman
[Applause]
that's right
so the last time you were here you
showed us some beautiful arrangements
using fresh flowers
take me through
how
we accomplish a dried flowered look what
are we doing today so some flowers you
can just leave in the vase and they just
dry in place for example eucalyptus
status here
and other flowers it's best to hang
upside down so that when they dry in
place they dry
nice and erect um now walk us through
how to actually do that teach me
christopher teach us yes so i just take
a piece of chicken wear crumple it up
and i try to make it as messy as i can
and then often very careful of my
fingers because i don't want to poke
myself
so just kind of crumple it up and then
we have one here you put it in your vase
just like this
i love this and then you can just poke
your flowers into it and rather than
having them flop all over the place
they'll stand right up are there any
flowers that are like better
in the
uh dried flower realm or
flowers you should stay away from
like it'll get smelly and won't preserve
uh lose all their color
what's what's better what's best in
practice i was sick you just brought
over some lavender lavender obviously is
the best because it's not only beautiful
but it smells great
these are straw flowers which even when
they're live they look dry so they're
really really convenient
why
why do you think that it's more
economically beneficial also to love
dried flowers oh my god i mean if i sent
you
live flowers to last for a week if i
give you dry flowers to last a lifetime
what is a flower brooch what is a flower
bridge let's talk about it
so um you can use your taller stems just
like you did in an arrangement like this
and if you have a bunch of small stems
you can just use a piece of twine tie
them together
and then
i know you're wearing one flower i just
want to demonstrate how amazing
christopher is yours is so beautiful and
mine looks nuts
and all of these are these the brooches
these are those can be used for brooches
or in little glasses like that so that i
might put on my windowsill in my
bathroom on my kitchen sink and then a
brooch you have a little pen here you
can just pin it right to your
um okay and uh the dried flower confetti
confetti yes so how do we do that so if
you have lots and lots of dried flowers
you can make a big arrangement with the
big stuff you can make a little brooch
with the little stuff or you can also
put the little brooch on like a gift
that you've gift wrapped it's just a
little accent i love gift wrapping with
some i love to take um the bags i get
from the grocery store the brown paper
bags
cut them up reverse them tie them
together with some twine and put some
little flowers and then mark it with a
sharpie like too so and so love me yeah
and then with your super extra stuff
like dry flowers are very brittle so
you're bound to sort of have petals and
leaves falling off all over the place so
you can take those leaves and use it as
confetti at a party or wherever you want
yeah then show me demonstrate like how
would one
show the confetti all right ready yes do
it here we go
[Applause]
i also have to say
i think this is such a beautiful
centerpiece on a dining room table
take a runner
that's something that's like a cloth
linen take a wooden bowl and look at how
beautiful this is
this
this is romantic to me yeah and it's
funny because i think sometimes when you
have your flowers and they tend to pass
away
they get thrown out and i think there's
a whole life to be lived there
and the way that you've arranged flowers
are so beautiful and the way they dry
flowers i i literally i have christopher
arrangements all over the apartment that
are just in preservation because they
dry so beautifully they really do
if you just put a little something
next to your sink or bring a little
color into your world it can stay there
and spark joy so i thank you because
we've been talking about doing this
segment
of how to preserve dried flowers now
if you go on our website um all these
diy floral tips um from christopher will
be on there at the drewberrymore
show.com christopher freeman thank you
thank you so much
[Music]
you